so hello everybody so I'm raghavendran a  research consultant and Mentor with omex  logic and find biotech I'm trained in  bioinformatics and hold up by a PhD in  computational biology from Max Bank  Institute of Germany my research  interest and focus is on data science  techniques such as machine learning and  deep learning methods applied to  integration of multi-oh mixed data like  a gene mutation data gene expression  data and copy number variation data my  role in point biotech includes  developing curricular and mentoring  students in research fellowship program  please let me talk about one one example  where I developed machine learning  models to predict human response for a  variety of treatment options employing  multi-amix integration of gene  expression data with copy number  variation and gene mutation data